hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and today
we have a couple videos to showcase
today one of them being this video and
this is all going to be about the new
character soon doors on whoo I'm still
getting the name pronunciation wrong but
it's gonna be strictly about the
character we're gonna be going over the
move set the feets as well as the armor
and weapons that they had showcase was
always like to be if you do enjoy a
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started
so season 12 is going to be launching on
November 7th just a quick update I just
wanted to let you guys know that but now
into the moveset so for the move set he
has loads of moves and all of them are
chain attacks he has a light light chain
heavy heavy chain light heavy chain and
heavy light chain so all the options for
a two-hit combo he also has a dash
forward heavy and light and a side dash
heavy and light as well as a zone attack
and a sprint attack so this man has all
of his bases covered his zone is unbel
and he has a crushing counter move
basically called subdue encounter blow
to perform the move you must dash into
the opponent move them press gb to drain
some of their stamina his zone is Undong
for some of us here are specific things
all finishers are unblockable and since
all moves are chains including the zone
and dodge attacks you can now zone into
unblockable light from any direction
zone into unblockable heavy light into
an blockable heavy dash attack into
unblockable light you have so many
options with this character you can also
cancel the recovery of opener attacks
dodge attacks and zone attacks by doing
another dodge attack is zone attack or a
finisher so this man has everything you
could just generally feint the heavy for
the heavy dash forward as well kind of
like JJ can do so you could obviously
hard feint it all the dodges have
superior block as well and whenever you
dodge you go of court you look and of
course that direction and superior block
for those that don't know our our blocks
that stop all chain attacks that being
heavies and lights if it wasn't the case
you would usually be able to block a
light attacks from continuing a chain
but heavies can continue to push through
because that's how the game is with the
heart of combat system
but would superior block it stops all
heavies from including the chain so
really a simple block can shut down a
chain attack very quickly and of course
this is how you can perform doing the
subduing counter blow we talked about
earlier using that superior block for
his feats he has the normal four feats
like everybody else does and they all
seem to have some type of team feat one
is a small projectile dealing low damage
and setting the opponent on fire if the
target is already on fire by the time
they get hit by this move then the thing
will explode doing additional damage it
doesn't do a whole lot of damage I
believe it's ten to fifteen damage so
nothing crazy but it is to like that
character on fire for free - it is a
gunpowder trap just like any other trap
but you can actually throw this as a
trap so it's they considered a grenade
trap in a sense and this explodes and
burns anyone within the range doing some
minor damage phiiiy is where we really
start to get into the heavy stuff this
is a passive in which all of your
attacks and feeds deal more damage when
the target is on fire
so I believe they showed in the showcase
that they heavy attack a side heavy I
believe is thirty damage but with the
fire that side heavy now does forty two
so it's not a crazy increase but it is
still an increase nonetheless and since
you have feet one and two being all
about fire these go together moving on
into tier four this is where you set the
ground aflame setting everyone on fire
within the area basically there's this
giant white circle that appears and if
you're caught within that circle by the
time it finishes wherever you are just a
giant flame stack of something just
reigns on down on top of you and this
will set anybody within that area on
fire you can set off one person or you
can set off the entire team as long as
they're outdoors and not indoors so all
of these feats pair really well together
with fire and I'm super excited to see
how this is going to work in the live
game so let me know what you guys think
about this but on the topic of the new
Wulin hero I want to talk about today's
sponsor project Orochi now if you're an
old fan of the channel you know that
I've worked or project Orochi in the
past on their season two drop and they
wanted to partner up again because
they're releasing their season 3 apparel
line they have loads of clothing with a
bunch of references like the Ken Satie
and the foo dog tee which is a reference
to tee on D and the Wulin as well as
references from Sakura with the divine
dragon hoodie and the corrupted T as
well and even a game of Thrones
reference with the fire and blood tea as
well so if you want to get some really
stylish clothing that is in currency at
all to wear like some brands like to
advertise a definitely go check out
project I wrote you down in the
description and you can use the discount
code heavy on red for a discount as well
and if you understand that reference and
you were real one as always thanks the
project wrote you for sponsoring the
video let's continue on with the content
hope you guys enjoyed that little bit of
an ad but going into this we have the
armor and the weapons now they didn't
show all of the armor but they did show
all the weapons roughly and for the
armor you can see big beard variations
some shaved some you know medium-sized
beard some of the bigger beards if
you're into that type of thing obviously
maybe some have shaved heads or
different types of hair options so lots
of stuff going on with the facial
section of the character and of course
if you didn't know you could play as a
female and a male just so you know and
like I said they didn't show all the
armor just so that they didn't want to
spoil everything which is exciting to
see and even one of them had this weird
demon mask which is really cool to look
at and the chest and arms aren't as
crazy and variation as you may notice
what the helmets for sure in the upper
body is definitely really crazy with the
helmet section being all different types
of things so I'm really excited to see
what people could come up with a lot of
the legendary gear was shown in here
they didn't specifically state which is
legendary which is not but you can kind
of assume just based on how much detail
was put into each of the armor sets
which one is high level or not next up
they showed the weapons and basically
they explained the shape of the weapons
will obviously change every time you get
a new one with different levels of
detail coming into each weapon some have
basics some have very detailed hilts and
guards so you can definitely notice a
huge difference it looks already by the
ones you're probably seeing on screen
one even had a bamboo on the hill which
was this green sword which is what I'll
definitely be using cuz that looks
really cool even the ones and the higher
one even though ones unlike the higher
ranks and stuff look even crazier I even
saw some some with like a wood handle
some with glass coming out at the bottom
so that looks really cool and the last
one was actually super super curvy so
that might even be one I'm definitely
using I don't know about you guys but
honestly just pairing the armor together
with all these weapons this character is
gonna look absolutely brutal and as you
guys saw from the gameplay to the weapon
showcase you can clearly tell that the
weapon
during the weapon showcase that the
these this weapon that he wields is
definitely a hell of a lot bigger than
it seems and it's really cool to see
that that's really about it when it
comes to the new character we got a lot
more stuff going on within the show I'm
just basically doing this in the middle
of it
we got the season twelve weapons to talk
about there was the season twelve
executions which I forgot to wake up to
record because I completely forgot that
that was today that's my fault that
video is gonna be out as well and with
that season 12 video that's gonna be
coming with the weapons some new
improvements a lot of balance changes
are coming this season with a decent
amount of character some including
Raider hito kiri so if we stay tuned for
that was those like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribed for new I cover
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
it we kept it today with everything
happening then the world before honor I
never miss out on an update deftly stay
subscribe the channel that guys take
care I hope I see you guys in a couple
of minutes there were a couple hours
when the new video drops as well I guess
for stopping by peace out and enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]